[Applaudissements]
je sais que c'était un peu tendu en
dissimulant fait une barca je suis
désolé on se casse débarrassa faut
d'abord un peu c'est dommage
témoin ce prix du bois un peu inquiet ce
prix que nous créons donc elle va dire
du mr
à wimbledon je te dis comme ça je sers
mon ami zone uc le donné cela tu as dû
vouloir faire de la pub pour la marque
non non si la tendance est en train de
toujours un bon bain à quoi ça sert de
t'entraîner puisque tu veux pas de
battre au
[Applaudissements]
je pense que j'ai 40 combats plus le
toit c'est vrai
bah oui mais je n'ai pas besoin de toi
même c'est une mi temps mais je n'ai
même pas besoin de deux j'ai même pas
besoin d'eux oui sinon au niveau des
streaming on et comment on rigole ans
adorent ce genre d'actifs mais j'ai des
gens qui vont y croire on réalise
évidemment des boutons bien pourquoi
attendre le faisons maintenant des gens
mais non je voudrais dire parce qu'il ya
plein de gens qui vont y croire
j'aimerais bien moi on est hyper potes
by van on adore se valent et commencez
vraiment tout le temps sourit avant de
venir il ya même quand j'étais convoqué
donnera à fond se voit lui
[Applaudissements]
c'est toi qui me convaincre que tu lui
en bord de voie ferrée qu'il est venu me
voir dans ma loge là on à caullery
victoire qu'est ce qui t'arrive la boîte
en question tant que tu connais alors je
ne vois tu sais quoi parce que je parle
beaucoup beaucoup ta gueule je vais te
proposer des mecs tu vas dire si tu
penses que tous les mois en bagarre
bouaziz accord tyson réfléchir ça
l'autre on stallone je sais pas si c'est
[Musique]
la bonne
je pense tout bas oui parce que c'est un
acteur mais laurent romejko des chiffres
d'état alors maintenant l'usap aussi
gras dur mon poto gras durs ce qui se
bat ouais on peut pas savoir tout ça
c'est un truc qui finit passe partout de
fort boyard
je crois que jean claude van damme mon
pote jean claude van damme avec qui on
prépare un gros truc non plus et
patrouillent à c'est le patron attention
si je te dis booba mais le petit tour
sur je ne sais pas non voilà et enfin
mike horn je connais mike horn
l'aventurier ne connais pas mais je leur
donne je pense pas répond celui de la
cyrénaïque et là tu vas pas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est un des coups et car il peut rester
huit heures à l'issue de l'arrêté
licence